c'est rare en tous les cas qu un showman
de ton niveau revienne aussi vite sur
scène non j'avais une idée surtout su
sublime quoi les dix agneaux et des
hommes toi donc c'est une idée qui était
depuis longtemps dans ma tête de me dire
j'avais lu cette phrase que l'homme est
l'animal le plus évolué de la planète et
qui devrait s'en féliciter chaque matin
c'est à dire je suis en pole position de
la chaîne animal
ouais ça m'a tellement fait rire parce
que je me suis dit on est battus souvent
par l'animal est tout et voilà c'est
venu c'est venu très vite et j'avais une
mine d'or en devant moi il ya but qu'à
taper dedans donc je me suis dit
pourquoi attendre alors jean marie quand
je t'ai demandé des informations sur son
nouveau spectacle
voilà ce que ma fac c'est jean marie
bigard voilà voilà le nouveau spectacle
de jean marie bigard alors je vais te le
filet puis à partir de ça tu fais ici
nous et moi je remplissais c'est vrai
thierry cain j'ai acheté donné ça c'est
pas une blague mais ce code le matin où
j'ai écrit ça j'avais il avait pondu mon
spectacle j'ai dit voilà mon spectacle
il est là c'est quoi les trois trucs
ouhlala les trois grandes différences
etc l'homme par rapport à l'animal ces
scientifiques un gi nissan pas moi qui
le dis c'est que l'homme à la conscience
de sa conscience et peut pas dire qu'il
l'a pas il a un il a un langage articulé
complet c'est énorme ça il peut dire oui
la malle camp s'il a eu mal
et puis troisième truc l'homme sait qui
va mourir ça c'est pas un super
avantages qu'un seul animal mais
l'animal lui ne sait pas qui va mourir
j'ai rappelé au dernier moment
c'est étonnant alors organisation
sociale c'est quoi par exemple alors à
brême a évidemment les grands chapitres
l'organisation sociale c'est entre les
animaux et les hommes de toyal et grands
la vie en groupe on vient en groupe
comme les animaux on a des patrons les
animaux ont des chefs de meute
la famille la migration la communication
récents rouge par exemple c'est quoi
parce que le poisson rouge lui par
contre il se fait pas chier dans le
bocal parce que il a que trois secondes
de mémoire ah bon le bois son origine
avec de trois secondes de même c'est
vrai ça s'est senti qu un on a déterminé
qu'il est avec 3 grenoble s'est jamais
chier soit par exemple l'état sont à
attendre je vous le fais tu peux tu peux
ne s'était pas prévu mais je vous le
faites en juin donc le poisson rouge
dans le bocal by the singles avec sam
oeun femme que me fait chier tube
fichiers j'ai perdu mon pote fraises ja
contrôle fiscal ok tu fais chier fait un
tour de bocal diésel dit a pensé à
appeler fred pour bouffer on a des
nouvelles d abu fait un tour jouera dame
sympa cet appart
tu as vu le buffet sympa cet appart à
vue fait merci et la migration c'est
quoi écoute j'ai écrit ce spectacle avec
laurent baffie je veux dire mon laurent
baffie mon petit frère parce qu'il est
vachement pointues sur les animaux se
connaît et on s'est régalé parce que il
ya un moment où toi j mois qu'a joué des
centaines de milliers d'oiseaux comme ça
qu'ils partent en même temps au même
moment toi comme ça me dit il ya bien un
couple ou deux dans la banque qui a pas
envie d'y aller
à zhuhai j'imagine les deux femelles qui
discutent qu'ils disent de moins avec
ray man show pas si on va y aller je
tenais je veux dire si ce but s'est tapé
dix sept mille bornes comme l'année
dernière 1 pour arriver à ruiner de
fatigue sur un rocher couvert de merde
si c'est pour se taper les martineau
comme l'année dernière avec leurs gosses
qui piaillent 1
et ben moi je sais pas si on va y aller
les saumons les saumons les deux
semaines
à l'origine elle dit à l'hôtel dix mois
déjà nouvelles frontières plus jamais il
permal flécher le parcours on a tourné
dans les sphères brodeur au milieu des
bateaux à votre trouver le fleuve alors
après on a remonté 400 bornes à contre
courant je fasse tuer la galère 1
alors et en plus l'accueil là-bas
excuse-moi deux kilomètres de l'arrivée
ghislaine ses prêts une grande tarte
dans la gueule par un ours
il n'y avait rien fait elle même pas
regardé rien il aurait voulu la bouffe
et s'y serait pas pris autrement
et dire on est arrivé j'étais fatigué
fatigué j'avais plus qu'une envie
c'était d'accoucher et de repartir mais
maurice ils avaient plus envie de rien
la preuve j'étais obligé de le branle et
au dessus d eux
l'audition
ordinaire je savais pas que le mérou au
bout de cinq ans il passait deux
femelles à mal
voilà la daurade celle inverse elle
passe de mâts la femelle c'est vrai il y
en a et c'est tout à fait authentique
là vous pouvez vérifier vous faites
internet par exemple il ya un poisson
qui s'appelle le barbier ou la
castagnolles rouge tu vois tout un
programme
lui il passe de mâts la femelle n'est
pas uniquement fonction de la croissance
mais katia trop de mal dans le troupeau
alors moi j'ai fait la fête de la
castagne rouchy c'est la fin de l'année
le vega
il se voit dit fait 1-1 1-1 il allait
dire excusez moi interrompre la fête de
la castagne rouge mais bon vous avez vu
cette année il ya un petit peu trop de
mecs
donc je vous annonce une bonne nouvelle
il ya jean raymond easy qui a décidé
spontanément de changer de sexe on
l'applaudît jean-raymond dialogue
il abroge faedy jean-raymond aiguë a été
un des plus grands ni coeur de la bande
on est fier de toi on est vraiment ému
alors que c'est ce qu'on va faire on va
boire un dernier verre entre potes et
appréhendent bourg
alors ces spectacles donc c ou c kan
s'est tourné de rodage comme d'habitude
je pars faire un petit tour de france
une quarantaine de dames
après je fais une dizaine de zenit en
décembre du 10 au 18 décembre et ensuite
j 9 un petit peu parce que je veux pas
faire toi tout paris et toute la brosse
à braid ans que je fais tout en même
temps c'est à dire qu' après je serai
présent trois jours par mois au zénith
de paris et dans toute la france donc je
fais je fais tout en même temps ça rend
pas mégalo comme ça de haranguer d'aidé
foule de plusieurs milliers de personnes
avec la voix booster avec son image sur
des écrans géants c'est tellement c'est
une scène c'est une drogue dure mais en
même temps comme c'est le métier que
j'avais choisi ça devrait le seul truc
que je sais faire mes amants aborde
beaucoup de pognon et du mal à renoncer
à leurs côtés non mais évidemment c'est
super grisant ce qui est super grise en
c2 de savoir que tu as pu attraper plein
de gens en même temps et surtout que toi
je discutais avec avec francis veber qui
atteint un maître dans l'art d'écrire et
il dit moi quand je lis aussi mes
scénarios aux gens physiquement je sens
si je les fais chier ou pas un toit par
exemple l'âge vient de faire des trucs
sur le plateau tous et pas l'endroit du
tout pour le faire et deux c'est trop
non mais c'est pas un mais c'est pas
pratique j'ai dit à des gens dans le dos
et au machin tu sais pas exactement
comment le réalisateur tac adresse à ce
trophée après juste l'oeil au moment où
tu faisais ça toi il a pris juste sa
toile à yves herman mais lui il a bien
fait sur mais bon tu sais pas mais même
en faisant ça et même dans ces
conditions là je sais qu'il ya deux
trois trucs par exemple je vais coller
un peu plus de ce que j'ai fait chier tu
sens dans l'oeil si tu fais chier ou pas
l'aude et je crois que c'est comme ça
qu'on fait ou qu'on fait pas une belle
carrière c'est quand on a le souci de
secours donne à l'autre mais tu le test
et ses copains toute la journée tout le
temps tout le temps je suis incapable en
ce moment par exemple de faire autre
chose à un dîner que la moitié de mon
secteur
si je fais chier tout le monde je suis
obligé de changer de potes tous les
soirs
parce qu'ils en ont jusque là ne
connaissent par coeur